if I want this hundred dollars I'm just
gonna have to repress my gag reflex and
just choke it down that sounded terrible
my name is Ryan my name is Troy hi my
name is Kevin and today we are doing the
hundred dollar $100 $100 rule a speech
at Taco Bell easily one of my favorite
fast-food restaurants I'm not a big Taco
Bell fan out of all of the fast foods
it's probably my least favorite it's
very affordable I like the food I didn't
know what fast food we were doing when I
came in but when I saw Taco Bell I knew
I had it in the bag underneath one of
these plates there is a $100 bill taped
to the bottom you all grab a plate you
must finish what is on that plate once
you finish what's on it you will be able
to look underneath and if you have $100
bill you won if not you choose another
plate and you keep going okay my
strategy is all about plate selection
I'm gonna eat as fast as I can that way
I have the most chances to win $100 my
grandmother is psychic and so I'm gonna
channel her spirit into my body and let
her help me pick which one is the right
plate I feel pretty good about my
chances I'm worried about eating this
many tacos from a place that I don't
normally eat honestly is it weird that I
don't feel like I have a big challenge
I'm gonna beat them I'm confident in
this challenge I've done I was like
trash-talking with Troy and Kevin
outside this is bringing out the the
frat boy and he I host a lot of hundred
dollar challenges challenge and a lot of
people in the comments say that they
want to see me do it so here you go
Internet I hope you enjoy ready to win
$100 three two one go oh wait and then
just eat okay
right right okay my plan going in was to
choose the right plate and not worry
about my eating speed and then I had my
first bite of a Doritos locos taco ever
and he was still like feeling ok then I
look over to my right and I see Ryan has
inhaled his taco soon as it touches my
lips I knew I had it this is like a
Friday night for me okay I'll flip it
over and oh my god
Rose that's my grandmother's name and I
really was upset with her she probably
is a really psychic so it's fine okay
Ryan was beating me but I still had
Kevin so okay as long as I could stay
ahead of him just keep it pace I just
need to eat as many and get more plates
it's a numbers game at this point
eating the second one my heart started
to race and I didn't know if it was
because I was excited or because the
Taco Bell was giving me heart
palpitations was a Friday night finish
second taco was a little bit more
discouraged I definitely felt like I was
gonna get sick I've never eaten tacos
this fast so I can only imagine how this
is gonna be on the back end as you can
tell I'm sweating I saw her I flipped
over his plate so I said okay I still
got a shot
I left my water pick the third plate and
I feel very very confident in this done
I can't beat these guys on speed so I
really have to make sure that I'm
choosing what I think is the right plate
plates are like to win dueling and I
just need them not to be winning mmm my
favorite day of my job ever I've never
been athlete but at this moment I felt
like maybe I found my thing glad that
Ryan got it cousin the rest of the
challenges he's terrible I don't know
what I said I know I just screamed
something out yeah I really want to
thank mr. Bell grandma and you know you
guys for watching
[Music]